[Music]
hey what's up mkhd here okay i've
already reviewed the iphone 14 pro and
14 pro max you can watch those at the
link below the like button the dynamic
island the camera upgrade
all that the bottom line is that is a
far more interesting set of phones that
has a few things that are actually new
to the iphone which is kind of cool the
iphone 14 on the other hand uh not so
much not so much this is almost the
exact same phone as last year so do you
remember those s updates we used to get
like we'd have the iphone 5 and then the
iphone 5s and then s for speed because
it was the same phone but just faster
this phone is even less of an update
than those s upgrades used to be and so
that's what i want to talk about in this
review is this new repackaging strategy
thing that apple's been doing especially
more lately with a bunch of their
products so this year we do get an
iphone 14 and an iphone 14 plus this 14
is out now and the 14 plus is coming out
in a month in october it's basically the
same thing just bigger 6.1 inches here
6.7 inches there and so many things are
the same as last year's phone on the
outside the design is the same the
iphone 13 cases literally work with the
iphone 14. like this is the new ali
abdowl dbrand grip case on the iphone 14
it's pretty sweet but then again here is
my iphone 13 from last year and
yep
fits perfectly
but yeah same squared off sides same
button placement same camera arrangement
same antennas same speakers etc and then
on the inside it's literally the same
chip from last year it's the a15 bionic
again technically a slight bump up with
the extra gpu cores that was in the 13
pro
but i mean yeah last year's chip too now
technically you could say these are all
things that i liked about the iphone 13
so hey if it ain't broke don't fix it
right that's apple but that also means
that a lot of things that could have
stood to improve that could have gotten
better
also didn't change so it's the same
display with the same brightness and the
same 60hz refresh rate in an 800 phone i
mean it would be so unlike apple but i
really would have loved to have seen
like 90 hertz here
but yeah same storage options same
battery size same charging speeds same
lightning port the way i see it it's an
iphone 13 again a year later with some
tiny improvements matter of fact here is
a full comprehensive list of every
single thing that's technically new okay
crash detection
satellite connectivity display
resolution e-sim new colors better
thermal design better repairability
design
new primary camera and new selfie camera
well this should be easy so crash
detection is cool it uses some new
sensors inside the phone and combines a
bunch of data from the gps and
microphones etc to notice if you've been
in a car crash and if you have it'll
notify emergency services without you
having to do anything it's cool it's a
nice feature i hope i never have to use
it and then if you're in the middle of
nowhere with no cell service and you
still need help the iphone 14 series can
now communicate with satellites in case
of emergency to help you get your
location and your needs to someone at a
dispatch center that's coming to the us
and canada in november that's another
nice feature
that i hope i never have to use the
display is technically a slightly higher
resolution with slightly thinner bezels
but you will definitely never notice
that
and the new lineup in the us is now also
e-sim only to be fair the setup process
and transferring service from my
previous iphone's physical sim was
actually super easy it's like maybe two
minutes tops and most other phones
coming out today new also support esim
so i'm hoping the transfer process in
the future is also smooth but yeah no
physical sim card tray here in the
states there also is this new blue color
then again most of you like an extremely
high percentage of you have said that
you use a case on your phone so
i wonder how many of those are clear
cases and then apple did mention an
improved thermal design inside this
phone for the same a15 bionic chip which
can help performance at the edges of
normal use cases so like playing a game
for a really long time or navigating
with high screen brightness with the
phone in your dashboard in your car on a
hot sunny day things that might get
extra warm have an added layer of
protection against throttling i think
that's something the pro users will care
more about but i definitely won't
complain that it's also here
and the better repairability design was
mentioned also near the end of the
keynote it's a little thing but it's
actually pretty surprising from apple
which is that the glass back is now a
separate piece from the rest of the
internals making it easier to replace
cool but easily the biggest physical
change with these new iphones is going
to be the cameras so there's a slightly
new 12 megapixel primary camera the
ultrawide is exactly the same hardware
and a new 12 megapixel selfie camera
with autofocus now i spent a bunch of
time looking back and forth at pictures
i took on the iphone 14 and the iphone
13 trying to pinpoint the improvements
it's like a game of spot the differences
and there are some differences but they
are so slight so this new camera is
still 12 megapixels but it is a larger
sensor so the individual pixels are
bigger and should let in more light and
then the max aperture went from f 1.6 to
f 1.5
in regular daytime lighting there is
pretty much no difference like the
iphone is perfectly capable of crisp
detailed natural looking photos when
there are no challenges just like every
other 800 phone always has been really
the only difference i'm seeing is maybe
color temperature the iphone 14 can take
some occasionally cooler photos and it's
noticeable if you have the right colors
in the picture
but here's a shot from the iphone 14 pro
with the 48 megapixel pro raw shot for
context here you can actually see a bit
of a difference it's a slightly
different focal length but also more
importantly there's lots more fine
detail here and just for fun here's the
pixel 6 pro same shot another great
detailed photo but just looks like a
different style but as expected most of
the differences between these that i
found were more on the edge cases of
normal photography that more challenging
or extreme
lighting situations mostly in low light
and so some of this is enabled by the
slightly larger sensor and faster
aperture
some of this is also enabled by the new
image processing pipeline that they've
tweaked and fiddled with that they also
named photonic engine you know on stage
they were saying things like 49 better
low light performance which i'm not
exactly sure what's meant by 49 like is
it 49 faster shutter speed or 49 less
noise in low light unclear but as i go
through the photos i took on both i
gotta say they're still
remarkably similar okay again i was
looking for the differences in the
amount of noise in the shadows or
dynamic range but really what i mostly
found was slight differences in color
temperature you know sometimes one might
be a little brighter than the other
and sometimes it's really hard to tell
them apart even pixel peeping i even
looked at shutter speeds which may
sometimes reveal that you actually have
a faster shutter speed from the bigger
sensor because it's taking in more light
and while i found that they were nearly
the same for every shot the iphone 14
was typically maybe five to ten percent
faster the one thing i did find was that
in the absolute darkest shots in the
worst conditions there was sometimes a
difference in how much time it would
require to get a night mode exposure
like for this one it took 3 seconds from
the 13 but 2 seconds from the 14.
even though the 13 actually ended up
focusing more correctly and had a bit of
a sharpness advantage in this shot
sometimes you just got to get the shot a
little quicker if possible and then this
one from the ultrawide it was a one
second night mode exposure from the 13
but just a regular snap from the 14. so
it's the exact same hardware i guess
that's the difference for the photonic
engine and image processing
even so
the image is a toss-up like it's a
little more processing happening on the
iphone 14 side maybe a little more
sharpening a slightly different color
cast but that's it and then on the video
front it's even more similar so they
take basically the same video but the
iphone 14 does have a feature called
action mode that's not coming to the 13s
for some reason even though it feels
like a software feature but it's
basically a super aggressive
stabilization for running around and
chasing stuff on top of the already
pretty good stabilization from the
iphone's video and i will say the
stabilization part works very well
but the video itself can be quite noisy
also it seems like in almost every
environment it's just asking for more
light all the time like you get this
dialog box that says more light required
but it still lets you shoot but the
footage is super grainy and soft
especially from the ultra wide that it
defaults to but also like i'm in an
incredibly well-lit studio and sometimes
it would ask for more light even in here
this is better lit than most people's
homes where you're chasing around a
baby or a pet at 100 miles an hour let
alone sometimes going outside on a
cloudy day and it's asking for more
light that's crazy so this may get
better over time as of right now it
shows up less on the iphone 14 pro which
makes sense because this one has a
larger primary sensor
but yeah the stabilization works really
well it's a software feature you might
use and then there is the new selfie
camera it is 12 megapixels and has
autofocus for the first time instead of
the fixed focal distance from before you
can get sharper shots in some less
conventional selfie situations which is
great um it's not game changingly
different i mean it's another
incremental improvement it can still
struggle with properly reproducing
darker skin tones which i mentioned in
the 14 pro review here's the same shot
from the pixel 6 pro which specifically
has their real tone optimization so you
can see what i mean so at the end of the
day what are we left with
a super incremental update in the same
body basically as before
and that's what i want to talk about
that they've done a lot more recently
some might call it the tim cook
logistics touch see that's been the
iphone se formula
for years i've talked about it in those
reviews so the first generation iphone
se comes out it's basically the body of
an old iphone 5s but with new internals
then the second generation iphone se
comes out it's the body of an iphone 8
but with new internals and then the
third generation iphone sc again that we
just got this year again is the body of
an iphone 8 but even newer internals
and there's rumors of the next gen sc
being like the body of an iphone 10r
but the new chip
and we even saw that with the macbook
pro this year the 13-inch m2 macbook pro
is the exact same body as the 13-inch m1
macbook pro just with better internals
now it's not exactly some mystery why
they do this there's plenty of reasons
behind the scenes why these things are
good for apple it reduces risk
it reduces cost because now you don't
have to develop as much new stuff
and then prices go down and you can
offer something more tried and true that
already worked in the past but to an
audience that will pay less and also it
sort of insulates them a little bit from
the supply chain challenges of trying to
make a bunch of newer stuff so the
innovation aka the risk is saved for the
even more expensive phones you know you
watch that iphone 14 pro review and you
see the dynamic island which is a thing
that's new to the iphone it'll evolve
over time you see the new 48 megapixel
camera system which is new to the iphone
and you'll see the always on display
which again is the first time they've
done this basically this is all just a
long-winded way of saying the baseline
iphone with this strategy is just boring
and that's just the way it is uh so now
for those who are thinking of actually
buying one of these phones you're
thinking oh okay i know everything about
the phones i know which one i want to
get but one last wrench to throw into
all of this
is that the iphone 13 is still on sale
and it's 6.99 from apple but you can
probably find it even cheaper from other
places
and i think that would be a fine upgrade
for a lot of people like the one extra
year of software updates is maybe the
only reason i would get a 14 over a 13
but aside from that you really got to
think about how much
the new colors or the slightly new
camera or satellite connectivity or
crash detection
actually means to you and hey if
efficiency means something to you then
definitely check out this video's
sponsor anchor who makes these chargers
and cables that i really like this is
their nano 3 charger which uses gallium
nitride that's why it's 70 smaller than
apple's 30 watt charger and it's still
powerful enough to juice up an iphone or
an ipad or a macbook air if you really
wanted to and this 541 cable which is
usbc to lightning is the first that i've
seen that uses bio-based materials in
the cable so sugar cane and corn but
it's still a high quality cable that can
withstand up to 20 000 bends and it's
actually more durable than a typical
plastic cable and these both come in
five colors for your choice to either
match your iphone 14 or mix it up a
little bit definitely check both of
these out at the link below but that's
been it thanks for watching let me know
what you think of apple's this
repackaging
re-gifting strategy that they've sort of
leaned into more lately either way it's
september a lot more is coming up
definitely subscribe if you haven't
already and i'll catch you guys the next
one
peace
[Music]